to answer do you believe kevin
mcmahill's two female accusers
well all i know is that
one particular i don't know anything
about the other female accuser the one
female accuser has been
impeached
for lack of integrity and another case
that i've become aware of and quite
often i got asked questions first of all
i think this is a ridiculous question it
has nothing to do with running this for
the state of
nevada for the governor's position
and
but i will opine on it and i will to
discuss it because you're questioning my
ability to endorse this individual i
believe that's the direction you're
going with this and i support kevin
mcmahon one hundred percent this is an
incident that took place 25 years ago
and he went through the due process
associated with that and he was cleared
associated with those crimes he had
worked for three previous sheriffs
prior to me before rising up into the
ranks and i eventually made a decision
to make undersheriff and he did a
fantastic job during his tenure as the
undersheriff
mr lombardo thank you you mentioned
she was impeached have you seen
documentation to show that in 30 seconds
yes i have
okay thank you didn't